FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi everyone.
Thanks so much for
coming today.
I'm very pleased to welcome
Time Wise to Google today.
Tim is an American anti-racism
activist and writer.
He's the author of six books,
including the highly acclaimed
memoir "White Like Me,
Reflections on Race from a
Privileged Son." His next book
"The Culture of Cruelty, How
America's Elite Demonize the
Poor, Valorize the Rich and
Jeopardize the Future," will
be released in winter 2014.
Please join me in welcoming
him to talk to us today.
TIM WISE: Thank you very
much for coming.
I'm particularly grateful
that you're here.
Because even though I've done
this for a very long time, and
now about 24 years of doing
anti-racism work of some sort
or civil rights work of some
sort and about 18 of those on
the road speaking to folks
around the country.
You never really know when
somebody asks you to come in
and talk-- whether it's at a
company or whether it's at a
college or a high school or
occasionally a middle school
or community group, wherever
it is I go--
who's going to show up.
How many people are
going to show up.
How much interest there is
in the conversation.
One of the reasons in particular
you don't know that
nowadays, maybe even more so
than when I began this work so
long ago, is that in just about
every sense, all the
other voices in the culture-- at
least the majority of them,
if not all--
seem to be telling you in a
lot of different ways that
this kind of conversation
really isn't necessary.
That we really don't have
to have this talk.
That we don't have to address
issues of race or racial
equity in the workplace or in
the school system or the
justice system or the housing
market or anywhere else.
Because to hear those voices
tell it-- and again, you'll
hear this echoed through
the media.
You'll hear this echoed
through the words of
politicians and talking heads
all around the country.
We're living in this--
presumably, in their mind--
sort of post-racial era where
these conversations, though
they were very, very important
a while back, they're now,
like, so 1965 or something.
Or maybe even 1995, if
we're being generous.
Or maybe even 2007, if we're
being really generous, right?
But now that we're in this
post-racial era symbolized, of
course, first and foremost by
the election not once but
twice of a man of color as
president, you don't have to
have this conversation.
I don't need to give it.
You don't need to hear it.
In fact, I remember immediately
after President
Obama was elected the first
time, I opened my email the
next day and knew there would
be all kinds of wonderful,
lovely things that people
would have to say to me.
And one of them was especially
pertinent to this
conversation.
It was all capital letters.
So you know you're dealing
with crazy when it's all
capital letters and they're
e-screaming at you, as if I
wouldn't have known they were
pissed if they had taken the
caps lock off.
And the email was something to
the effect of saying, well
now, you're going to have to
find a new hustle, right?
Because that's clearly what
fighting racism is, is just a
big hustle to make a lot of
money and get very famous.
Because that is exactly what
you would do if you were
sitting in a dorm room at the
age of 19 thinking to
yourself, what the hell would I
do if I wanted to get really
rich and really famous?
Oh, I would fight
white supremacy.
Because that always
works out well.
So anyway, it said, you should
get a new hustle.
Because now that Barack Obama
has been elected, clearly we
don't have to have this
conversation anymore.
Racism is dead.
And you're going to have to find
some other line of work.
Now, if that were only one
voice and an angry email
saying that and the day after
an election, then maybe I
wouldn't have taken it very
seriously, just like I don't
take most of the emails that I
receive all that seriously.
But unfortunately, that mantra
was repeated, usually in a lot
more erudite way than that.
Without the capital letters.
Without the electronic
or real screaming.
But by people oftentimes very
well intended and quite
sincere in their belief that
we're living in this sort of
post-racial era where this
conversation is not important.
Of course, if we just think
about it for maybe two
seconds, we can recognize, I
hope, almost immediately why
the notion of post-raciality
is absurd.
At least if the only evidence
you have for it is the
election of a black
man as President
of the United States.
If you have other evidence,
feel free to present it.
But if that's the sum total of
your evidence-- if that's
exhibit one and two and three
through seven, then you're
probably not a very
firm ground.
Anymore so than we would have
been on firm ground if someone
were to have said, let's say, in
Pakistan in 1989, the year
after Benazir Bhutto, a woman,
was first elected president of
that country, that
sexism was no
longer an issue in Pakistan.
Patriarchy has been smashed.
And this we know, because
a woman is the
head of state in Pakistan.
Or when Margaret Thatcher was
elected in Great Britain.
Or when Indira Gandhi was
elected in India.
Or Golda Meir in Israel.
Or Corazon Aquino in
the Philippines.
So in all of these countries--
you can probably think of
others-- there have been
female heads of state.
We still haven't had one.
So if I were to suggest, for
instance, to my two daughters,
who are 12 and 10, that what
they probably really ought to
do if they want equal
opportunity as women is pack
up their bags and move to
Karachi, my guess is that even
the 10-year-old, who has no idea
where the hell Karachi
is, would know that the odds
were that wasn't a good bet.
Just because a woman had been
the head of state in Pakistan
did not mean that other women
were going to, therefore, have
equal opportunity.
So we wouldn't make the argument
about sexism in those
countries just because they've
had female heads of state.
And I would hope that we would
be able to see through the
argument about race as it
relates to this country.
But it's very easy to get sucked
into that rhetoric of
post-raciality.
And I think maybe it's more than
ever possible in a place
like Silicon Valley, where more
so than just about any
other sort of industrial
area of America, both
geographically and historically,
there is this
very widely accepted mythology
that this, more so than any
other part of the American
economy and any other part of
the geography of the country,
is this pure meritocracy.
All those other industries,
no.
They're not really
meritocratic.
We know that there are
networks and there's
clubbiness and there's cultures
that get sort of
reestablished and resurrected
and passed on, but not here.
There's no such thing as
clubbiness or insider
advantages or networks, or even
a criteria that might
itself not be all that
meritocratic in Silicon Valley.
Well, the smirks on some your
faces at least suggest to me
that you've thought through this
a minute and realize that
some of that rhetoric
is quite well sold
but quite a bit overblown.
Because ultimately, at the end
of the day, we do have to ask
ourselves one very
simple question.
When people tell us that this
industry or that industry or
that this country or the
overall economy or this
particular company is
meritocratic, it then begs the
question, right?
That if in fact this company
and the larger part of the
economy that it represents and
of which it is a part is truly
meritocratic, then you would
have to really ask yourself
some hard questions about what
that means in terms of who
possesses merit in this country
and who doesn't.
Because if you have an entire
area, both of the economy and
a geographic region, this being
the Silicon Valley where
only about 6% of all the
employees in the various firms
and companies here are black and
Latino, and you believe at
the same time that this is a
pure meritocracy as a part of
the economy, then you would have
to actually come to some
very racist conclusions almost
by definition, right?
You would have to conclude
that only 6% of the best
people are represented by
African American and Latino
folk who collectively, in
the country, represent
approximately 30% of the
population and in this state,
quite a bit more than that.
You would have to assume
that there was this
real dearth of ability.
This real dearth of merit.
This real dearth of interest in
having jobs in the growing
part of the economy.
As if somehow black and brown
folks would prefer to stay in
embedded in parts of the economy
that are rapidly dying
and leave all the really great
jobs disproportionately to
those who were white and of
course, on a gender level and
sex level, those
who were male.
You would also have to assume
some very sexist things.
If you really buy into the
notion of Silicon Valley as a
pure meritocracy, you would have
to assume that men are
just that much damn smarter.
And just that much better at
doing certain types of jobs.
Now, there may or may not
be evidence for that.
And you may believe there is.
But certainly not to the
extent we see the
disproportionalities in not
only this sector of the
economy, but in old sectors
of the economy like
manufacturing, where the same
kind of thing was true.
Is it really true that women
were only 1%, 1 and 1/2%, 2%
of the people qualified for jobs
in the old quote unquote
economy in certain companies,
firms, or industries.
Well, probably not.
But if you're going to accept
that premise, understand where
it leads you as we try to have
these conversations.
If you're going to assume that
Silicon Valley or that Google
itself as an entity is a pure
meritocracy, you would have to
assume not only some very racist
and sexist things about
certain folks, which would then,
it seems to me, have an
impact on how you perceive even
your co-workers who are
women or who are people
of color, right?
Because if I actually look at
people and think they're part
of a culture or group of people
that are in general not
as good, that are in general
not as qualified, how do I
really relate to the one or two
that I actually work with?
Or the five or six that I
see on a regular basis?
How do I subdivide my
brain into the part
that says, oh, no.
This person's just as good
as anybody else.
But the group they're from
is really screwed up.
Is that actually something
the human brain
is capable of doing?
Saying on the one hand that
I believe this group to be
superior to this group, this
group to be harder working,
this group to be more
innovative, this group to be
better for this particular kind
of job, but there are a
handful of y'all that are OK and
I'll be able to keep that
in mind as I work with
you on a daily basis.
And the psychological research
says that's not likely.
So in fact, if we buy into the
stereotypes, we're likely to
perpetuate the very culture
that maintains those
inequalities, even if we don't
necessarily intend to do it.
So how would we know if
we were a meritocracy?
How would we know if racism were
operating in a company or
in an industry?
How would we know
if sexism were?
Well, those seem like obvious
questions, but they don't
really have obvious answers.
Because when you ask them, how
would you know if racism was
operating, you ask a hundred
people that, you're going to
have a lot of different
answers.
One thing we know from history
is that if you're really
wanting to figure out if racism
is operating, the first
thing you don't want to do-- as
a general rule, with some
exceptions-- is ask
white people.
Just being perfectly honest.
Just like if you want to know
if sexism is operating, you
wouldn't start by asking men.
Just wouldn't make sense.
If you wanted to know if an
industry or a company were
discriminatory toward those
with disabilities, right?
On the basis of ablism, you
wouldn't ask the able-bodied.
Because when you're a member of
a dominant group, whatever
that is-- whether it's race,
gender, sex, class, sexuality,
religion, educational
background, or
whatever it might be--
those individuals who are
members of dominant groups--
and we're all, in just about
every case, members of at
least one or two.
Everyone I see in this room
has probably got a mix of
identities.
Some of which make you a
dominant group in certain
categories.
Others of which make you a
subordinate or potentially
targeted group for
mistreatment and
discrimination on the other.
When you're dominant, why would
you be expected to know
what other people who
are not experience?
It would be sort of irrational,
wouldn't it, for
me as a man to actually have a
keen insight into what women
experience in terms of sexism.
Now, I might know.
I might know.
And if I do, it's probably
because I listened to a woman
describe her reality and decided
to assume she was
actually sane and not
overwrought, not
overemotional, not hormonal.
Because apparently a lot of
guys think only women have
hormones, which is
fascinating.
Testosterone does
nothing to us.
Estrogen is a killer.
It'll totally jack you up.
Men would not be the ones
for whom you would seek
information and insight
about sexism.
Not because they can't know, but
the odds are, that's not
going to be your best bet.
Same thing with race and
asking white folks.
Or going to white folks are
asking them, do you think
there's racism in
Silicon Valley?
Well it seems to me it would
make more sense to start by
asking people of color about
their own experiences.
And they're not all going to
have the same opinion on that,
by the way.
They're not all going to have
the very same experiences.
But in general, it's probably
a safe bet to say that if we
want to know if a problem
exists, the people to whom you
would first turn are the people
who were most likely to
have to know the answer to that
question as a matter of
daily survival.
If I want to know if racial
profiling happens in New York,
I don't ask people
on Wall Street.
Because even though they might
need to be racially profiled
based on their own past
criminal endeavors and
activities that have helped to
tank the economy in the last
six years, we know they're
not going to be.
And if they spend their entire
time in Battery Park and they
spend their entire time on Wall
Street going to really
nice restaurants where the NYPD
never bothers them, and
you ask them if that's
happening, they're probably
not going to see it.
And here's the thing.
They're not going to see it even
if they're good people.
And in fact, I'll go so far as
to say, they're not going to
see it precisely because they're
such good people in
many cases.
And I mean that seriously.
Like most people, I
think, are good.
Most folks don't want
to oppress others.
Most men don't actually wake up
in the morning seeking to
marginalize women.
But we manage to do it even
though we didn't wake
up with that goal.
White folks don't wake up with
the goal of reinscribing white
supremacy every single day and
subordinating people of color.
But the evidence as we manage
to pull that off even if it
wasn't our intention.
Why?
Because when you're a good
person, when you have all the
right sort of ideas and
ideologies and ways of
thinking and you think you're
very open minded, it's
oftentimes that precise person
who's the most dangerous.
Because it's that person who
doesn't want to look at the
ugly, right?
And by that I mean, who doesn't
want to look at the
injustice that might be in their
community, whether it's
at a company or whether it's at
the school or whether it's
in a neighborhood or whether
it's some private club to
which you belong.
Because if you're a good,
caring, compassionate person,
you look at the ugly and
then you realize
you're on the hook.
You actually have to do
something about that.
Because you're a good person,
now you feel like crap.
If you were a sociopath, this
wouldn't be a problem, right?
And the good news is-- and there
is some-- we're mostly
not sociopaths.
So make sure to write
that down.
Tweet that.
Whatever you need to do.
It's like, we're not mostly
sociopathic, but because we're
not sociopathic, we look at the
pain of racism or sexism
or classism or homophobia and
heterosexism, and for people
who really are compassionate, we
turn away from it almost as
quickly as we turn towards it.
Because to be reminded of it,
and to be reminded that we're
sort of in the midst of that,
is to put us on the hook.
And we really don't like
to be on the hook.
Because there's only 24 hours
in a day, seven days a week,
365 in most years.
And so as a result, we just
don't have extra time to deal
with all the problems
that we have.
And so we turn away from it.
So I think the first lesson
when we have these
conversations is as glad as I
am to be here and as honored
as I am to be here-- and I'm
very happy to be able to speak
to you and to other folks
around the country.
If we're really going to get to
a place where we know we've
created racial equity in a
company or in a community, or
gender equity in a company or
community or sexual equity in
a company or community, it's
really important that we get
to a place where we can hear all
the stuff that I'm saying
and I'm going to continue to
say for a few more minutes
from the people who
are the targets.
It's fine for me as a straight
white male to stand up and
talk about this stuff.
And upper middle class with
a college degree, and
able-bodied.
And here I embody all of these
privileged groups.
But until we're able to also
hear women say it without
getting defensive as men and
getting pissed, right?
Until we're prepared to hear
people of color say it
without, as white folks,
getting pissed.
Until we're prepared to hear
LGBT folks say it without
those of us who are straight
or cisgendered or gender
normative getting angry and
upset and pissed off.
Then until that happens,
we're really not
in a place of equity.
Part of the problem, I think,
when we have the conversation
is that we usually are coming
from very different places in
terms of how we're defining
the concepts that we're
discussing.
So if you hear that there's
going to be a conversation,
it's about racism, you
automatically have certain
assumptions about what we're
going to discuss
and what that means.
And naturally, as good people,
we don't want to think that
we're implicated in racism.
My god, if there's racism in
my company, then that means
that's on me.
But we're thinking of racism in
a very sort of traditional
way when we use that term.
And that's what gets
us in trouble.
That's what, if we had heart
monitors on people, when you
say, we're going to have
a talk about racism.
If you had heart monitors,
you'd see the
blood pressure spike.
That's what the research--
people get very nervous when
they think we're going to talk
about this.
And the reason is, they think
they're going to be called a
racist, right?
And that if they are somehow
called a racist, that we mean
they're got there Klan robes in
the closet and they brought
them in on the bus or the bike
or however the hell they got
to work today and they're going
to the neo-Nazi rally
and they are actually skinheads
in disguise.
And people make those
assumptions.
And so as a result, they
get very defensive.
Nobody wants to be thought
of as that.
If we had a different
understanding, though.
If we had an understanding
that racism is
not principally that.
That when we're talking about
racism in the modern era, it's
not that that stuff
isn't still there.
It is, right?
And those of us who do this work
long enough, we get death
threats from folks like that.
They still are around.
They don't actually
ever go anywhere.
You call them neo-Nazis, but
really there's nothing neo or
new about what they do.
It's sort of paleolithic
or Jurassic Nazis.
They're decidedly old school.
But there's still around.
But that's not really
the issue.
And it's certainly not the issue
I assume that I need to
address in a corporate
setting.
If it is, I'm screwed.
I need to get the hell
out of here.
And we're all wasting
our time.
If we're actually in a place
where there's such overt
hostility and bigotry of the
nature of hate group activity,
then nothing that I can say in
45 minutes, or that anyone
could say, is going to
solve that problem.
But if we understood that racism
is much more nuanced
than that, particularly in the
modern era-- it might have
always been more nuanced, but it
certainly is now-- then we
can have a much better talk
without the same levels of
defensiveness.
So when I use the term racism
and I talk about racism as a
problem, I am not presuming in
this or any other company to
which I speak, or at any school
where I speak, or
community, that we are mostly
talking about malicious
individuals who are
deliberately
seeking to harm others.
Though I know they're
there, that's not
what I'm talking about.
And that's not what
I'm focused on.
Likewise, you don't necessarily
have to assume a
direct intentional
victim or target.
So neither the perpetrator of
racism nor the victim of
racism has to necessarily do
anything consciously to make
the injury take place or to
get in the way the injury.
In fact, sometimes we talk about
racism, we're not really
talking about it in the overt
one-on-one I don't like you
therefore I mistreat
you kind of way.
We're talking about in a much
more systemic sense.
And just like any ism that you
can think of, just about, is
both an ideology and a system,
the same is true with racism.
Think about that.
Capitalism.
Socialism.
Communism.
Fascism.
Authoritarianism.
What are these?
They're ideologies.
They're also ways of organizing
a society.
They're also systems, right?
And you can sometimes be in that
system even if you don't
accept the ideology.
You can be in that system and
by virtue of your actions,
perpetuate that system, even if
you don't buy the ideology.
Materialism is a good
example of this.
Materialism we understand.
If I go to the store and I
engage in some impulse
purchase, right?
We understand what--
I mean, maybe in the
moment, I don't
understand what I'm doing.
But later on, I think
about it.
I'm like, why did I
buy the candy bar?
I didn't want chocolate.
And I didn't go for the
"People" magazine.
What the hell is
wrong with me?
But I picked up the "People"
magazine and I picked up the
candy bar because why?
Well, because the marketers
put it there.
The people who actually stage
the stores put it there,
knowing that someone's going
to buy that and be part of
this larger system of
consumption and materialism.
Of consumerism.
They could have put
the chocolate on
the chocolate aisle.
They could have.
There's a candy aisle
in every grocery.
But they didn't put all
the chocolate there.
And it's not like they just had
some left at the end, and
then were like, I don't know.
What the hell do we
do with this?
Oh I don't know.
Just put it up near the
place where they pay.
Like that was some kind
of coincidence.
It was very deliberate, knowing
that even though your
mentality--
you didn't wake up
and go, I am a
materialistic consumerist hack.
I can't wait to go buy crap
I don't need today.
Nobody does that.
But you fall into it.
And therefore, that's
why they continue to
keep the candy there.
If everybody made a conscious
choice not to do that, they
might rethink.
But they know that we can fall
into those cognitive traps
when they're trying
to sell us stuff.
That's what companies spend
billions of dollars, including
this one, to market stuff.
Google spends I don't
know how much.
I know it's a lot, right?
To market stuff.
And it works.
If it didn't work, you'd
get new PR people.
You'd change your whole
approach and
you're whole strategy.
People spend money to convince
people they need this.
They need to think this.
They need to act like this.
Dress like this.
Be like this.
Own this piece of technology.
Own this vehicle.
Live in this neighborhood.
Because it works.
And if you can be convinced of
the kind of computer that you
need to have, or if you can be
convinced of the kind of
smartphone that you need to
have, or if you can be
convinced of the kind of toilet
paper that you need to
use so as not to chafe,
because oh god, no.
Downy, that'll never work.
Or Angel Soft.
No, I need Charmin.
Charmin knows if they spend
enough dough that you'll maybe
fall into that.
To the extent that they can sell
us products, commercial
products, with advertising.
How much easier is it, you
think, to internalize over the
course of a lifetime all of the
commercials, if you will,
that we've been given about
race and racial others.
All of the commercials that
we've been given and exposed
to about gendered
and sexual and
religious and class others.
Because we've been seeing that
commercial since we were
children, so to speak.
Over and over again.
And people who are marketers
will tell you, and people that
are in marketing and advertising
will tell you, it
only takes about 12 commercials
for a particular
consumer product before all of
a sudden, you begin to see
brand loyalty and you begin
to see an uptick in sales.
It's the law of 12.
Some people call it
the law of 11.
If they're really good,
they can do it in 11.
But usually, it takes
a dozen commercials.
And after a dozen, it's like,
damn, I need that product.
And so ultimately, I guarantee
we've certainly been exposed
to racial stereotypes
more than 12 times.
We've been exposed to gender
and class and sexual and
religious stereotypes
more than 12 times.
Some of it, since we were
very, very young.
And so the odds that somehow
that hasn't stuck to us or
that it stuck to all those
other people out
there, but not here.
Not at this company.
Not in this valley.
Not in this industry.
Incredibly unlikely.
Not a very parsimonious
expectation.
I would suggest that it's
probably the case that there's
not such rarefied air.
I mean, I'm breathing it.
It seems clean in here.
You all filter your air very
well, from what I can tell.
As opposed to the salt flats
as we were coming in, which
were not nearly as nice.
But ultimately, the idea that
the rarefied air here is so
different that those things that
beset the mere mortals in
the outside world wouldn't
happen here,
pretty incredibly unlikely.
So if we can let go of
our concern about
bigotry being the issue.
If we can let go our sense that
to be accused of racism
is to be accused of being a bad
person, or to be accused
of perpetrating sexism is to
be accused of a bad person.
Then, if we can let go of that,
we can have a real,
meaningful conversation.
What are the ways, you think,
that we can perpetuate, if you
will, racism, sexism, other
isms, even without
intentionality.
Because that's the stuff that
unless we think very
consciously about it, we'll
make mistakes and not even
realize that we've done it.
The obvious stuff, the answer
is, just stop doing it.
But the stuff that's so
subconscious you don't realize
you're doing it, or that's a
matter of systemic practice
and you never reflect on
it, is the stuff that
goes under the radar.
So what are the ways that can
happen with racism, with
sexism, or any other ism?
I would suggest there
are three ways
with regard to race.
One is this notion, this real
myth of objectivity.
And now I mean this on
a personal level.
This idea that we are actually
capable of objectively
evaluating the merit of
another human being.
I know we like to believe that
we're capable of this.
We really do.
You'll hear people say
it all the time.
Well, it's not racism,
we just hire the
most qualified person.
As if somehow, there are 310
million Americans and it is
capable to rank them from one to
310 million, and then say,
well, you were 167,412.
You've got the job.
Or you were 2,000,307.
Sorry, you don't quite
make the cut.
Or you were 11.
Hot damn.
We have found the 11th most
wonderful human being on the
planet for this gig.
That isn't rational.
But we act as if somehow, we
can just take people's
resumes, take their background,
sit them down in
an interview for a few minutes,
and then we can be
the sort of perfect receptors
of information, whether it's
their background or the answers
they give us to the
questions that we ask.
And that we can just filter it
out like a computer with no
biases whatsoever.
And we believe this, in part,
because we want to.
It's a lot nicer than to think
that we're incredibly flawed
and incapable of really
being objective.
But what the evidence very
clearly tells us is that we're
not nearly as capable of it
as we'd like to believe.
So that when we think about jobs
and hiring and promotions
and evaluation of existing
employees, in just about any
company this would be true.
At any college in the
admissions office,
this would be true.
At any graduate school, business
school, med school,
law school, same thing.
The notions that often affect
who gets hired, who gets
promoted, who gets admitted,
what the evaluation of the
employee is, are affected by--
those things are affected by
the notion of fit.
Who does and does not.
The notion of qualifications, by
which we really are talking
about formal credentials, not
necessarily qualifications.
Because qualifications can
be quite intangible.
Credentials are very clear
and they're on paper.
And some of them are probably
quite important.
Others, maybe not
so objective.
But we certainly utilize them.
And those are really
the two things.
There's not three.
Just fit and credentials.
And yet what the research tells
us is that the notion of
fit is incredibly subjective,
more so than just about any
other concept, perhaps,
in the workforce.
Especially in an industrial
culture, in an economic
culture, that is its own sort
of the universe, right?
Which is true of tech, but
it's also true of heavy
manufacturing in the past.
They created cultures,
did they not?
And the people that were seen
as fitting in with that
culture, they didn't
all look the same.
They didn't all have
the same story.
They didn't all have the same
education or background or
accent or religion.
But there was a certain
continuity.
Even with the diversity that
existed just in people's lives
and family backgrounds, there
was still a lot of similarity.
There were certain expectations
about affect,
about dress, about style, about
your hobbies, about the
things that you would do.
And if those things affected who
did and didn't get hired,
who did and didn't get promoted
in the auto industry,
for instance, or if it affected
who did and didn't
get promoted, who didn't
get the gig in--
forget manufacturing.
Think about police departments
or fire departments, where no
doubt, the people who were
getting hired for most of
those jobs were probably
qualified for
them in some sense.
The fire department was not
generally picking people who
were incapable of
fighting fires.
But the idea that they were
actually capable of figuring
out who were the 20 best
firefighting human beings in
this community, pretty
unlikely.
There was all this other
intangible stuff happening.
And the research tells us that
the notion of fit is directly
affected and impacted by racial
bias, gender bias,
class bias, sexual bias, all
of those and a lot of other
types, too.
And that we tend to see merit
more quickly in someone that
reminds us of ourselves.
Whether that's in terms of our
background or in terms of our
interest or in terms-- it
could be something as
intangible as the music
that you like or
all kinds of things.
Do you do cross fit
or something?
I mean, it could be anything.
God forbid, right,
it could be that.
But the point being that this
notion of fit isn't really
about objective evaluation.
And to the extent that it can
be affected by racial bias,
gender bias, class bias, all
these things that the research
tells us we internalize from
the time that we're very
young, then even when we think
we're being purely objective
and fair minded in the hiring
process, the evaluation
process, the promotion process,
we're not really able
to do that.
The second principle
way in which we can
maintain racial bias--
and this would be true
for other biases--
is that there's also this myth
of institutional objectivity.
So it's not just that our
personal biases--
many of which are subconscious,
according to the research--
get in the way of how we
actually evaluate people.
That's part of it.
But this other part, which is
even more frightening, is even
if we were capable of being
perfect evaluators of other
people's merit, the problem is
the criteria we're using to
determine merit may
itself be flawed.
May not be as objective
as we think.
So even if we were objective,
the criteria might not be.
What do I mean by that?
Well, you think about maybe the
most meritocratic merit
indicator that there is.
What would it be?
If you're hiring, you would
think, well, it seems like the
best indicator is experience.
That seems fair.
That seems objective.
That seems like a pretty
good merit indicator.
But the problem is when we
determine whether someone does
or does not have as much
experience as makes them
qualified, we oftentimes set
incredibly arbitrary limits on
that or frames around that or
a particular definition of
what experience is that is not
really objectively arrived at.
I've worked with companies
that--
I always make the
habit, usually.
I didn't do it this time.
But I usually make the habit
of going and looking at the
last, like, 10 job postings
that I can find for a
particular gig.
Just to see what they're
asking for, right?
And you go and it'll say,
five to six years.
Four to seven years.
8 to 10 years.
Two to three years.
And I'll go and I'll ask the
folks I'm working with, like,
OK, where did you
get that number?
Why four to six?
Why not three years,
four months, two
weeks, and an afternoon?
Why?
What was the actual objective?
Other than just picking a
nice, round number, what
evidence do you have
the four to six is
really what's necessary?
And that if you only had three
and a half, you'd be screwed
for another half a year?
No, you have to wait six more
months, and then come back and
it'll be fine.
And every time I've asked that
question, why this criteria as
opposed to that one, without
exception there's never been
an objective evaluation.
There's never been what's called
a reliability analysis
in this work done to determine
that this is really necessary
and without this, you're likely
to fail at this job.
Usually it's because that's
what the last guy-- and it
usually is a guy--
had to have.
So that's what-- by God, that's
what I had to have.
And if I had to jump through
those hoops, you're going to
jump through those hoops.
That's what's called
a positional good.
It's something that I have, you
want it, and I'm going to
make damn sure that you have
go through all the same
troubles that I did in
order to get it.
Now, the positional good may be
valuable as a criteria, or
it may be really strange.
So for instance, most of the
time, college professors have
to have a Ph.D., certainly
to be tenure in most
institutions.
And that might make sense.
But then you have to actually
ask yourself, well, what makes
a person get a Ph.D.?
What you do to get a Ph.D.?
Because it seems objective.
It seems fair.
It's the highest level you can
get in most fields, unless you
get a J.D. or something, some
other type of specialized
professional degree.
But is it really objective?
Well, let's think about it.
How do you get a Ph.D.?
You get a Ph.D. usually writing
a dissertation, which
is you write a really
long paper on
a very narrow subject.
It's not like you're doing
a survey of your
entire subject matter.
You're picking a really
narrow, finite area.
So Newt Gingrich, for example,
has a Ph.D. Now, I could end
the joke right there in some
regards, I suppose.
But he has one.
He has one, actually, from my
Alma mater, which I'm not
overwhelmingly happy about.
But it is what it is.
And he has his Ph.D.
in history.
He got this Ph.D. in history
because he wrote a
dissertation.
Fantastic.
That's what you do.
And because he has a Ph.D., if
Newt Gingrich wanted to be a
history professor at any college
in this country, he
could probably--
he probably also could do
that because he was the
Speaker of the House.
So that probably would help.
But even if he hadn't done that,
just the Ph.D. would
probably qualify him in the eyes
of most for being hired.
And yet, what was
his Ph.D. in?
Well, it was history.
But how did he get it?
He wrote a dissertation.
What was it about?
It was about Belgian
educational
policy in the Congo.
Fascinating.
And I suppose if you're a
historian of the Belgian
Congo, that is a very
important subject.
And if you were going to teach a
class on Belgian educational
policy in the Congo, I don't
have any doubt, Newt Gingrich
is probably your guy.
And that's actually arguable,
because when he did his Ph.D.
in Belgian educational policy
in the Congo, he didn't
actually interview any black
folks from the Congo.
He just interviewed
people in Belgium.
So even then, you might
say, he's not really
that much of an expert.
But we'll just cut him slack
for the sake of argument
because I'm feeling generous,
and we'll say that if you were
going to teach a class on that
subject, he probably knows
more about it than
a lot of people.
But does that mean that he's
more qualified to teach, like,
a US history 1865 to the
present survey class?
Not necessarily.
Maybe he is, maybe he isn't.
So even a really seemingly
objective criteria like that
can get us in trouble unless
we dig deeper.
And the same is true with
credentials generally, for one
very simple reason.
How we get them isn't just about
a fair race in which
everyone has started at the very
same point and has the
finish line in front of them,
and then whoever is the
fastest runner gets there.
We're talking about a larger
system of job networking and
job opportunities in which some
people have had three lap
head start in a eight lap race,
or five lab head starts,
or even just a half a lap
head start, right?
If I've had even a little bit
of a head start on you and
we're running a race, I'm
supposed to cross the finish
line first.
That's sort of how that works.
And in fact, if I have a head
start on you and I don't cross
the finish line first, there's
something wrong with me.
I'm not as fast a runner.
If I have a five lap head start
in a eight lap race and
when the race is over,
I'm only ahead by
three, I still won.
But you're the faster runner.
So if you were trying to pick
people for a track team, you
would want the person who made
up ground and closed the gap
in terms of achievement, rather
than the person who
just hit the tape first.
When we talk about jobs, it's
not quite like a race.
But it's not altogether
different either.
Because none of us are sort of
just starting from scratch.
Unless it's your very first job,
and even then you're not
starting from scratch because
you went to school somewhere.
And even that wasn't scratch,
because you had a family and
they had a certain set of
opportunities or lack thereof.
So in a sense, we're constantly
inheriting these
eight lap relay races.
But we're not inheriting
the starting line at
the very same point.
And so if we're going to
evaluate who's the most
qualified and we're looking only
at the tape at the end of
the race, which is what the
resume, in a sense,
represents.
The resume, the job references,
the application
that you fill out, that's the
end result of whatever you've
done before, which is great.
Just like the eighth lap.
And the tape is the end
result of the race.
But unless I know all the stuff
that happened in lap
seven, six, five, four, three,
two, and one-- or at least
some of the stuff.
I'm not going to maybe
know all of it.
But if I don't know any of it,
am I really likely to make a
really excellent, objective,
fair decision at the end about
who the most qualified
person is?
Well, I might get lucky.
But I could also be horribly
wrong if what I'm seeing is
just the detritus of
an opportunity
structure that's unequal.
Which is to say that both
ethically and practically, we
need to rethink the
notion of merit.
Ethically, of course, because
that means a lot of people who
might be the best are being
left by the side.
Not because they are any less
capable, but just because
maybe they don't know
the right people.
They haven't been in the
pipeline as long so they don't
have the same credentials.
But also because it hurts
institutional integrity.
If a company's trying to
actually find the best people,
which I think makes sense as
long as we have an expansive
capacious understanding of what
"the best people" means,
then they would want, I would
think, to have a criteria that
was less likely to produce
outcome based decisions that
were the end of the
eighth lap.
The tape at the end
of the race.
That they would want to have as
expansive a notion of merit
as possible.
And as holistic a way of
assessing merit so as to get
the best people.
Not only to be fair.
That's part of it.
But also to make sure that they
actually do, in fact, get
the best people for the job.
The final problem that
perpetuates injustice that
corporate folks need to think
about, educators need to think
about, and all of us, really, in
the country to think about,
is what I would suggest as color
blind formalism would be
the term that I guess
I would use.
And what I mean by color blind
formalism is this very formal,
very formulaic way in which we
just don't talk about race and
we don't think about race.
Or we act as if we
don't see it.
So when we talk about racism,
that's what people will say as
their first line of defense.
Well, I don't even see color.
I don't think about color.
Well, that may be the problem.
If you don't think about color
in a world in which color
matters, ten you're going to
miss an awful lot of stuff.
It'd be like saying, well,
I'm ability blind.
I don't notice disability.
Now, think about that.
The Americans with
Disabilities Act
was passed in 1991.
And if anyone said, well, our
goal is to be disability
blind, well then how the hell
are you going to build a ramp?
You're not going to build a
ramp for folks in chairs
because I'm not noticing,
because I didn't even see you
were in a chair.
Ergonomic workplaces,
what the hell?
I don't know anything
about that.
You need a certain width
of the door?
I don't know.
Why would I do that?
Elevators?
I'm not noticing that
you're disabled.
All the different things that
come with disability.
If I'm not noticing, then the
odds are I'm not going to take
the kind of steps that I need
to ensure that you actually
have equity of opportunity
in treatment.
And then I'm going to pretend
that I've been really innocent
and kind and nice.
Like, oh, but I didn't
even see you.
Yes, exactly.
And that's why you didn't make
the workspace more functional
for me and others like me.
The same is true with
race or gender,
sexuality or anything else.
If you're going to create real
equal opportunity, you have to
take a not color blind or gender
blind or sex blind or
sexuality blind or any
blind approach.
You have to take a very color
conscious, gender conscious,
sex conscious approach that
actually looks at the way that
these dynamics oftentimes skew
our own judgments and skew the
very criteria that
we are using.
To be blind to color, as Julian
Bond, civil rights
legend, puts it is to be blind
to the consequences of color.
So if the consequences of color
are still quite real,
being colorblind means we take
a very passive approach.
We just take it as they come.
Lots of times folks will say,
we'll hire whoever walks
through the door who's
most qualified.
The problem being, if certain
people know the location of
that door and they know which
way the door turns and they
know the combination code to
get through that door, then
they're going to have
a much easier time.
Or if somebody just simply
thinks that behind the door
will lie rejection, right?
So imagine if you're a member--
and like I said, all
of us in here are at some point
probably members of
dominate groups and also members
of subordinate groups.
I've rarely met anyone who was
only a dominant group, that
every one of their identities
was dominant.
And I've never met anyone
who's every
identity was non dominant.
Could happen, but it's rare.
So when you're a member of a
dominant group, if you think
about being anything but that,
what it would be like to go to
a place where you were so
incredibly under represented.
And you're making assumptions
in you're own head about why
that might be.
You're assuming, well, maybe
it's overt racism, sexism,
classism, et cetera.
Or maybe it's not.
Maybe it's just subtle bias.
Or maybe it's just the culture
of this institution is going
to be off putting and they don't
really think that I fit.
So if they don't think I fit,
I'm not even going to try.
Which gets to the heart
of the problem.
Sometimes in Silicon Valley,
where people will say, well,
there's just not enough
qualified fill in the blank.
Not enough qualified women
in this kind of work.
Not enough qualified people of
color in this kind of work.
A, that's oftentimes a dodge
and oftentimes inaccurate,
statistically speaking.
Let's just for the sake of
argument say for the hell of
it that even if it's true,
what does it mean?
Let's just say, for the sake of
argument, that there really
aren't enough to dramatically
change the demographics of
Silicon Valley, at least
not right away.
What, then, obligations do we
have to do something about it?
Do we just passively
go, oh well.
It's not my fault.
I didn't create that
imbalance.
It sort of sucks.
I wish it wasn't like that.
But I don't really have time
to think about that.
Or do we think, well,
wait a minute now.
We inherit this legacy for which
we're not to blame, but
we've inherited it and we sort
of have to be accountable to
and responsible for what
we do with that.
That's what we do as
responsible people.
I don't think any of us in
here are deliberately
responsible--
I hope not-- for poisoning the
water and the air and the soil
all around this planet.
You didn't actually take your
own bucket of hazardous waste
and go inject it in a deep well
into the water outside
the back of your house.
But it got in there.
You didn't go and belch
smoke with toxic
chemicals into the air.
But somebody did that, and now
you inherit the legacy.
And as a responsible person,
not just as a citizen of a
country but a citizen of the
planet, you have an obligation
to deal with the stuff that
gets handed to you.
So if we know that unfairness
and inequity has been handed
down to us, then we have to be
conscious about how we're
going to undo that.
You can't do that passively.
And ultimately, if you try,
you create incredible
dysfunctions.
It's not a sustainable
model, ultimately.
To be formally color blind.
To not think about race.
To not think about issues
of inequity.
Or to not challenge our own
subjectivities, whether
they're personal or
institutional.
Because here we are, in a state
that's already mostly
people of color, in a country
that's going to be roughly
50-50 white and people of color
within a mere 30, maybe
35, years at the most.
Maybe as few as 25.
So somewhere between 25 and 35
years from now, we're going to
be a half and half country
of white folks
and people of color.
Unless you actually think, and
unless folks throughout
American and in Silicon Valley
in particular, think that it
is possible to maintain a tech
sector on the back of a
dwindling percentage of the
population, which is
incredibly unlikely and
it's a pretty risky
gamble, I would think.
Unless we actually believe that
we'll just continue to be
able to cull 80, 85, and in
some cases even 90% of the
best talent from a group of
people that's shrinking in
terms of its size, then we'd
better think very seriously
about how we're not going to
just passively sit back and
say, oh well.
We wish there were more of
them, but there aren't.
But we're actually going
to go out and have
to create that pool.
We're going to have
to actually go out
and seed that pool.
Whether that means collaborating
with school
districts and individual schools
and mentoring folks at
a very young age when they're
actually thinking about what
they want to be and what they
want to do when they grow up.
I remember doing that when I
was in third or fourth or
fifth grade.
A lot of people don't
think about it
until quite a bit later.
But if I never know that
you exist or that your
opportunities exist or what it
would even mean to work here.
What it would even mean to
work in Silicon Valley
generally, at any institution.
Then the odds are pretty
good, it's just not
going to be on my radar.
If it's not on my radar, I'm not
likely to apply for a job
or seek a career in
the industry.
And if I don't apply, then
I can't be actively
discriminated against, in which
case I can't sue and
nothing ever changes.
I can't sue if you don't
actually mistreat me.
And you can't even mistreat me
if I don't even know you exist
or know how to reach you.
So we have to do that level of
very deliberate seed planting
in order to create a
different culture.
Not only for the sake of
fairness, which I think is
important in its own right,
but also for the sake of
institutional continuity.
Just like I would tell and I
have told prep schools all
around this country that have
been overwhelmingly white for
a very long time, that they're
going to have to think very
seriously about how long
they want to exist.
If you're going to be a boarding
school and you've
been around for 100 years living
off of the presence of
affluent white folks in a
country where white folks are
dwindling as a percentage of the
population, you don't have
a very good long term
chance of survival.
Ultimately, you're going to be
culling from a shrinking base.
So you've got to think about
change not just for others,
but also for yourself.
And so in this particular case,
I'm glad that there are
folks in the tech sector and
in Silicon Valley generally
who are willing to ask
these questions.
I only hope that you continue
to ask them without fear or
recrimination or anxiety that
somehow people are going to
look at you or others with whom
you work as bad people.
I'm sure there are such folks.
I'm sure we all know
some of them.
But the reality is that most of
us are good folks trying to
get it right.
Unfortunately if we don't
understand all the various
ways that we get it wrong--
because of the cognitive traps
into which we fall, because of
our upbringing, because
of our conditioning--
then we can't solve them.
The good news being the research
tells us very clearly
that if we are willing
to confront that--
if we are willing to own our own
biases and the extent to
which we've been conditioned to
see certain people as more
meritorious than
other people--
the research says that if we're
willing to do that, we
actually can check the bias
before it becomes
discriminatory behavior.
So you actually can interrupt
the thought before
it becomes the deed.
And ultimately, that's
what's important.
I don't know a lot of people of
color who are too worried
what white folks think
about them.
It's how white folks
treat them.
I don't know too many women who
are really that worried
about what men think
about them.
It's how they get treated
as women.
So ultimately, if we can
interrupt the thought before
it becomes the deed, then harm,
the damage, of racism,
of sexism, of all these isms,
can be if not undone, at least
interrupted and diminished in
terms of its ability to harm
others and, really, to
harm the society upon
which we all depend.
Thank you all so much
for being here.
I appreciate it.
I will take any questions that
you have in the time
that we have left.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
TIM WISE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
So at least in the realm of
sexism, I think there has been
some basic acknowledgement
that we are not--
that this is a major problem
in the tech industry and in
Silicon Valley with kind of
the rise of the brogrammer
culture in mainstream media.
How do you take from
acknowledgment of the
existence of this kind of
culture and get past the point
where, right now, it seems
like it's a preference.
Like you have a brogrammer
company or one
that is less so.
And it seems right now like it's
interpreted as a matter
of preference.
Like, oh, I prefer
to work here.
Not like, this shit
is unacceptable.
How do we stop it?
How do we move forward
from there?
TIM WISE: Right.
Well, I think it's
a good question.
Because obviously, we can
acknowledge it and not
problematize it.
And I think that's what
we tend to do.
We acknowledge certain things,
but we don't ultimately
problematize them.
Like we will acknowledge that
people tell racist jokes or
sexist jokes, whether it's in
the workplace or in the school
or in the neighborhood.
And then we will rationalize
that or not make a big deal
out of that or act like
it's not a problem.
So clearly, one does not
automatically lead to the other.
The good news is that
if we create--
and sometimes the critical mass
needed for this, and I
don't mean critical mass of
women in a male-dominated
sector or of people of color in
a white-dominated sector so
much as I mean a critical
mass of whomever
willing to push back.
And it might be in a certain
unit of a certain company or a
certain industry, just
a handful of
really committed people.
It could be several dozen.
It could be hundreds.
It might take more than that.
It's never clear, depending
on where you are.
But what the research find
is, and my own experience
confirms, that when you push
back, and when a handful of
people begin to push back
against the sort of unspoken
norms of the culture, and begin
to just question them
and to problem-- and to ask
questions really more so than
even make demonstrative
statements.
Because it's one thing to stand
up and say, this shit is
unacceptable.
And I'm all for that
a lot of times.
Like, there are times when you
just have to say it that way.
And then there are other times
when the approach,
particularly when folks are
really dug in on their denial
that there's a problem going
on, is to ask a series of
questions of them which leaves
very little possible
conclusion other than this
shit is unacceptable.
But it's different if I tell you
that or if you think of it
yourself, right?
It's like with my
own children.
If I want my children to do
something, there are two
approaches, right?
I can either say, like, in the
morning if it's time for
school, I can say, get upstairs
and brush your teeth.
We're going to be late.
Now, that works about
60% of the time.
Maybe a little bit better than
flipping a coin, but not much.
Or I can come up with a much
more inventive approach.
I can ask my daughter.
Usually it's just one of them.
The other one is a little bit
quicker on the draw with this.
But I'll ask what are
you supposed to
be doing right now?
Now, I know the answer is
brushing your damn teeth.
That's the point, right?
I could have just
told you that.
And you know it's that.
But if I tell you brush your
teeth, there's that part of
you that just, whether your a
kid or an adult and somebody
tells you to do something that
might be dug in and not doing
it and resisted.
But if I ask you and you say,
oh-- and she will-- brushing
my teeth, right?
And I go, exactly.
That's awesome.
Then all of a sudden, she
thinks she's a genius.
She thought up the problem
on her own.
She now came up with the
solution on her own.
So if I'm trying to get people
to really question the culture
of an institution with regard to
race or gender or class or
sexuality, sometimes asking
those kind of questions and
getting a handful of people who
are prepared to step up as
allies and ask those
questions.
And when I say, as allies,
I mean specifically this
requires that it's not just
people of color who are
raising this subject in a
white-dominated institution.
It's not just women who are
raising this issue in a
male-dominated institution.
It means that some of us who
are male and some of us who
are white and especially if
we're both, and some of us who
are straight and some of us are
working class background
or whatever it is where these
issues come into play.
We've also got to be prepared to
stand up and to challenge.
And what's really interesting
in the research is that when
that happens, you end up
discovering a lot of times--
not all the time, but a lot of
times-- that there are lots of
other people in the
institutional space who also
were thinking, this shit
is unacceptable.
But they didn't want
to go first.
Part of this is not that we're
ignorant or we don't
understand the problem.
Sometimes that's it.
But sometimes it's just, I
sort of know the problem.
I don't want to put
my neck out first.
I don't want to go first.
Nobody wants to go first,
because there's that chance
that you're going to get your
hand slapped or your neck
chopped off or whatever.
So you sort of hold
back and wait.
And as soon as someone else does
it, as soon as someone
else raises the issue, that's
when you'll start to see
people go, yeah.
I was thinking about that.
Now they don't feel
they're alone.
And so I think in a sense,
that's an important piece.
And it's also important to put
yourself in the middle of the
problem when you're
discussing it.
To say, it's not just
that the culture
generically is this way.
It's that I'm a part of it.
And I've imbibed it.
And I've taken part in it.
And I've contributed to it.
And I realize that
that's a problem.
Because just that level of
honesty and transparency makes
it easier for someone else to
be honest and transparent.
Otherwise, what it sounds like
is, this shit is unacceptable.
I'm good, but this shit is
unacceptable, right?
As opposed to saying, no,
actually, this shit is
unacceptable, but I also
am part of the
stuff that's not OK.
And the minute you allow
yourself to be part of the
problem, then other people
are willing to own
their piece of it too.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: So once you all have
this shit is unacceptable
moment and then we support
people so you start to have
women in the brogrammer culture
or more African
Americans going to college, et
cetera, how do we support them
once they're there?
TIM WISE: Well, I think the
key to that is you have to
actively continue to work with
and collaborate with people.
And with as opposed to for.
I was a community organizer for
about a year and a half in
the mid '90s, and one of the
things that I learned just
doing that work was if I was
going to work with communities
that were marginalized both
racially economically and
really just culturally oppressed
and dominated and
targeted and often times
devastated communities.
The only way I was really going
to be of any use as a
white man who had a college
degree-- and so in every way,
I had all the privileges and
advantages that most of the
people in that space didn't,
because not only were they
folks of color, not only were
they poor and usually not with
college educations, they were
also disproportionately women
in public housing, et cetera.
The only way that I could really
be of any use to them
in the long run was to start by
listening to what they said
they needed.
Not asking them in a voyeuristic
way, like, how can
I help you?
Because that gets old.
Like people who are constantly
being crapped on really don't
need you to say, how
can I help you?
Because you can help them by
not crapping on them, first
and foremost.
And so we just have to be
prepared to listen.
So I would go into the community
and I would listen
very carefully to what
was being said.
Not necessarily to me in
response to a direct question,
but just what were they
talking about?
What were the things
on their mind?
What were the things that
they needed to see
change in that community?
So that when I then got involved
in a campaign to do
x, y, or z, I knew I was
following their lead.
And the same is true in a
corporate setting or in a
school setting.
If you listen carefully to
what folks of color are
saying, or what women as women
are saying, and sometimes that
requires just keeping
your ears open.
Other times it might
really require--
and I think in the best
of cases, it does--
getting to know individuals
and creating
relationship with them.
Because if I do get to know you
on a one-on-one level and
I can hear your story and you
can hear mine and I can share
it with you, then I might be
able to figure out some way in
which I can assist you in
navigating a culture which
maybe was not set up for you,
but which I see as important
for you to succeed in.
And also, there's some
reciprocity involved.
Because even if, as a dominant
group member, I was in there
working with these
communities--
not for them, but with them--
I was still getting something
out of it.
It wasn't all a one-way
street.
It wasn't just that I was going
in and giving them the
technical assistance that they
needed to fight for a
particular piece
of legislation.
I wasn't just giving
them information.
I was also taking
something away.
What I was taking away was the
insight and the wisdom that
otherwise usually was totally
untapped and un-listened to.
And then I could take that and
take that out and talk to
other people about it in a way
that the people in the
community sometimes couldn't,
because they didn't have the
microphone.
So if I'm going to work with and
mentor folks who are being
marginalized on the basis of
some identity that, let's say,
I don't share, I'm able to
listen very carefully and not
only then maybe direct my
actions in a way that will
really help them, but more
importantly, I'm able to then
go and talk to other people,
maybe of my own identity.
Maybe I can go talk to other men
and challenge men around
sexism after listening to women
talk about what it is
that they need to see happen
in that regard.
Or as a white person, I can
challenge other white folks
perhaps in a way that people of
color also try to challenge
white folks, but oftentimes
aren't heard.
So I can take the wisdom and
then amplify that wisdom,
giving credit to the wisdom
where credit is due, not
assuming that it's mine.
But saying, hey, this is
the stuff that I'm
hearing from folks.
And I tend to start with the
assumption that they know
their needs.
And so I think we all should
start with that assumption.
So there are ways of amplifying,
ways of listening,
ways of subordinating sort of
your own assumptions about
what people need to what
they actually are
saying that they need.
A lot of times we might assume
that people need
a particular resource.
And that may be the one that
this person needs.
But it might not be the
one this person needs.
This person might
need this very
formal mentoring structure.
This other person might just
need one individual to whom
they can relate on a very
personal, not even
professional, level, in order to
feel comfortable when they
come to work.
So you have to learn to listen
and create connection with the
people whom you're trying to
move into the space where
maybe they're not normative
for the space.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Do you have any concrete things
that somebody can do on
any given day to challenge
somebody who just refuses to
see anything or hear anything?
TIM WISE: Well, I mean there's
no silver bullet for that.
And obviously, the people who
are truly dug in and refuse to
see things are usually
people--
they are movable.
Most people are not completely
immovable.
But the odds that you'll be
able, by virtue of some really
well-placed argument or fact
or even story, to dislodge
them when they're that dug in.
You might be able to do it.
But the amount of time you're
going to have to spend to make
that happen may very well not
be worth the energy that it
takes even if it works.
Those are the kind of people
that normally sort of have to
have their little come to Jesus
moments, where something
happens and the clouds part and
they're like, holy shit.
I need to change everything
I think about the world.
You're not likely to
give them that.
You might be able to, if you're
really persuasive.
But the odds are, they're going
to have to come to that
on their own.
So what does that mean?
Do we go throw up our hands?
No.
What it means is that
fundamentally, you start not
with the hardest cases
like that.
You're trying to
build a certain
amount of energy, right?
You're trying to build a
certain inertia towards
justice and toward equity.
So if you're starting with the
people who are not those folks
that you're describing.
But folks who say all the right
stuff and for the most
part, you can assess that they
mean it, at least in theory.
That they actually want
to do right by folks.
That they really do want equity
and justice, and they
know that these things
might be problems.
But they may not actually
be involved in
trying to change anything.
They know it here.
They're not necessarily
working on it in
an effective way.
Then you start to build a
certain sense of capacity.
Again, it's not just that people
don't want to go first.
It's that until they see
movement, they may not do
anything at all.
What I learned in public housing
projects when I worked
there as an organizer was the
thing that the people they are
needed more than anything, more
than me, they just needed
to know that they could win
a couple of things.
And if they knew they could
win a couple-- and I mean,
really minor stuff.
Not like major victories.
Just minor things, to give
them a sense of their own
power and their own capacity.
And then they start to do
the work on their own.
And they start to change the
dynamics in the community,
even though there are people
in much more powerful
positions that don't want
anything to change.
I remember going in, very
first week that I was an
organizer, and talking to
somebody about what are you
all fighting for?
What are you working on?
Because I was going to hit the
ground, be really excited and
interested in this.
And I figured he was going to
answer, well, we're fighting
to smash white supremacy,
because that's why I was
there, by god.
And we're going to smash
economic injustice.
Well, I mean all that
stuff is true.
That's their long-term goal.
But instead of telling me that,
he looked at me and
said, we're trying to get
a stoplight right there.
And I remember going, what?
A stoplight?
At a corner?
Like, what's that?
I mean, I know what it is,
but why is that such
an important thing.
And he said, well,
a couple reasons.
One is like four kids have
been hit on their bikes
because there's no stoplight.
So we need a stop light so kids
will not get hit on their
bikes because cars will stop.
So that's the most
obvious answer.
He said secondly, though, it's
more important, the reason
we're fighting for
the stop light is
because we can get it.
We can get it.
We'll win.
If we fight hard enough on this,
we'll get-- it won't
even be that hard.
We'll get the stop light.
And yeah, it doesn't
change anything
about the larger structure.
But it gives the community a
sense that there's something
possible in their actions.
That they can, in fact, fight
and occasionally get the
outcomes that they want.
That's what any group that's
subordinated--
whether it's economically,
racially, religiously,
culturally, terms of gender,
sex, sexuality--
needs is to know that it's
not a wasted struggle.
And the more that they know
that, the more they're
invested in the sense that they
actually have efficacy
and they have agency that
can be effective.
The more that they're going to
want to work with others.
They're going to be
less exhausted.
Less burned out.
They're going to be physically
healthier.
Because they know that even
though it's not going to
happen quickly, it can happen.
And therefore, you end up doing
an end run around some
of these really hard cases.
Ultimately, some of
them might change.
But the thing that will
change the most is not
anything that you say.
Not any story that you tell or
statistic that you offer or
fact that you give them.
But simply the example of people
on the move trying to
change the institution.
Because most people who are
really dug in like that also
tend to be very--
they just tend to be more
compliant people.
That's why they don't want to
think outside their existing
world view.
Because they tend to just exceed
to what they already
assume it's normative.
Well, if you start to create
change, right?
With or without them.
Now, that becomes normative.
And now that person that's very
compliant gets on board.
In fact, they'll get on board
and say they were down with it
all the time.
Like, oh my god.
It's like people will tell you
they marched with Dr. King.
Oh yeah, shit, I was
at every march.
I was right there next to him.
This person was like seven when
King was killed, but they
have added 20 years to their
age just to make you think
that they were at some rally.
That person or their parents
might have been horribly
opposed to the civil
rights movement.
But now, 30, 40, 50 years later,
they're like, oh yeah,
I was there.
I was at Woodstock.
No.
No, you weren't.
You weren't there.
And so ultimately, you just
create this energy, this
movement, that other people
end up feeling--
not all of them, but enough of
them-- feel compelled to glom
onto, even if it's for
the wrong reasons.
Their reasons for wanting to
jump on that bus may not be
the same as other people's,
but if they get on the bus
ultimately and take that trip
to whatever location justice
is to be found, then
they'll get there.
They may get there with a very
different purpose and a very
different level of intent, but
at the end of the day, if
they're there, then you've
sort of got them.
And so I wouldn't be my head
against the wall on the
hardest cases first.
I'd save that until--
unless you just feel really
persuasive and energetic and
you've got nothing else to
do with the five hours.
But ultimately, I think that,
for the most part, the thing
that gets folks like that is a
sense of inevitability, right?
That's certainly what got
civil rights laws.
It wasn't that Lyndon Johnson
woke up and said, oh my god.
I've been a stone asshole all
of my life and didn't even
vote for anti-lynching
legislation.
Oh my god, I'm a terrible
person.
It's like Nixon didn't wake up
and say, we've been bombing
and killing millions of
southeast Asians.
What the hell is
wrong with me?
I should stop this.
That's not what happened.
Ultimately, these individuals
felt that they
had no other choice.
You could've gotten somebody
more dug in on race, in a lot
of ways, than someone like
Johnson had been
early in his career.
You couldn't get anybody more
dug in on cold war mentality
stuff than Nixon.
And yet when they felt that they
had no choice, they ended
up making decisions they might
not even have wanted to make,
but they had to make them.
And that's the power of
movement activity.
That's the power of the
inevitable inertia that you
can create your own energy,
with or without those
individuals.
Thank you all so much.
I appreciate you being here.
[APPLAUSE]